[Music]
okay well
i always got room with my [ __ ]
oh
for both of us
we're doing a couple things today that
are brand and related
um like what [ __ ]
some things not everything brendan does
uh so
we're we're
somebody sent this to me with a time
stamp
um
this is brendan talking about because
he's really smart okay
talking about the mk ultra program b
takes a long time because i've got to
watch commercials because on the disney
channel you have to watch commercials
commercials on the disneyland no not
disney i mean history channel history
channel
yeah but they have a loan on do they
have a loan on netflix now one season
the last season oh they don't have all
the seasons on there no you know netflix
lost a million
i know
they're going they said it's going to
trend back the other way but they're is
it they linked up with microsoft to
offer a cheaper virgin version
oh my god he's declining he's getting
worse like i i that's a very good point
who's declining faster him or biden at
this point like
well it's kind of hard to tell because
one of them started way further down the
hill
yeah that's a good that hold on that's
fair but the other one had way more
punches to the head
yeah i mean i feel like he's gonna build
up more momentum
his is going to be like an exploding sun
is what you mean it's going to be just
it's going to be a thing to behold
it's going to be
a french kind of uh
genesee benoit
[Laughter]
hilarious are you saying we're going to
have a body by bowflex situation
[Laughter]
very funny man they're losing so many
subscribers yeah the content has been
great i want you know stranger things
though that was [ __ ] lit so they have
a couple of things that are great but
narcos stranger things they put a lot of
stuff out there that that doesn't do us
so well so it's like a ton of garbage
yeah yeah
like you're [ __ ] gringo poppy on
youtube
they should have that on netflix right
right in between the seven different
indian comedians that have specials now
on netflix for some reason
good specials yeah this stuff's just
anyone ever brought it up again but why
do they cross their legs like that oh
because they have vaginas
goddamn you beat me to it
that's why mostly to keep the smell in
from their gaping [ __ ] holes
that's right there's no this is going to
be limited this is going to have limited
monetization this clip that's for sure
[Laughter]
searching through like [ __ ] this i know
i know i was bummed out strange things
and and then i was uh watching this
interview i just turned out to send
attendant
but
but i've said this before but but he
talks like a sim
i i just want somebody to look he does
he does
he should have little things over his
head and he's like
[Music]
just sounds like a ricochet at this
point yeah that pico de gallo has
[ __ ] just turned into
brothers who wrote it and i thought this
was interesting
to like a burrito place
and because it's just gonna come out
like that oh no i'm afraid of going to a
burrito place because i might run into a
mexican and [ __ ] that noise oh yeah it's
just awful oh my god what if he's not a
dime piece like brendan's dad then what
then what i'm gonna hang around with a
non-dime piece mexican no thank you not
in my bucket
you've seen stranger things right and so
11 and like the guy that they call papa
oh my god he's a child explaining
stranger things jesus christ
you know he's doing experiments on mind
control and uh i love it when you call
me gringo papa the
creator of
it
[Laughter]
and he's on the floor the show the duffy
brothers one of them was saying that
that was all rooted in real
uh history
from the mk ultra project here it is you
ready
finally listen how many years because
all of us on this call know what mk
ultra is
super interesting i'm sure you guys guys
have read a bunch about it and and seen
a bunch of cool documentaries about mk
ultra but you guys personal victim here
but you guys know not you're right and
you guys know nothing here about that
virgie because now we're going to have a
true expert talk about mk ultra we're
going to have one of the smartest people
one of the biggest thinkers of our
generation
can i make a prediction absolutely you
know what this is going to be
this is gonna be brendan schwab trying
his goddamnedest to repeat [ __ ] that joe
rogan told him
at like two in the morning while they
were both completely hammered you're
[ __ ] right this is gonna be something
that him and eddie bravo said
like brandon shop was sitting in the
middle and joe rogan and eddie bravo
were having a beer talking about mk
ultra and brennan's like yeah b bro
that's crazy b
that's wild b the only reason he
retained any of it is because they were
sitting on [ __ ] each side of him and
the thoughts going through his [ __ ]
ears and his empty head [ __ ] smacked
into each other so he [ __ ] hung
around [ __ ] seriously every single
punch he's ever taken is like a scar in
his brain
and then so i went down this rabbit hole
looking up mk ultra where they were
using psychedelics so mk ultra was um
this scientist this old school scientist
jonathan jonathan ultra was his name if
i remember correctly
thought with michael keegan ultra that's
where the mk comes from
enough lsd
that was government jewish
well his real name they changed it
outside it was ultra steen
oh i thought it was ultraman oh ultraman
works too i like that one as well
ultra bird yeah government uh funded the
government bought literally all the lsd
they could get their hands on back in
the day you know the 60s 250 000 in lsd
which they said was the the all the lsd
in america about 250 thousand dollars
and then they would run experiments on
people a lot of prisoners a lot of you
know people that were poor they'd run
these experiments like your family
remember they brandon shop is a poor
family
he came from a poor family of
professional bodybuilders and computer
geniuses
i'm with lsd
and his hispanic family in the tuskegee
experiments
really that make you know what that
makes sense that makes sense
generational syphilis is a hell of a
drug this generational syphilis is the
name of my ska band
and they're going to be at the third
stage at bonnaroo this year
is because they thought right what's up
regenerational syphilis
sure and the nazis were doing it all
right
someone's cranking someone's cranking on
the stage
all right sorry bret listen this is a
once in a lifetime explanation
understanding of mkultra and you guys
are ruining it
with your ska music i think we're
punching it up okay
there's some improvement fair enough
fair enough where they could use mind
control so if you had a set of beliefs
if they give you enough lsd and pumped
all this propaganda in you
then it wouldn't hurt
yeah it's propaganda
not not negative ganda propaganda you
know what you know the problem with me
guys is that every time i have every
time i have ganda and it's just made
improperly it makes me upset so i prefer
propaganda you have ganda intolerance it
has to be proper yeah i can't look it
has to be propaganda
what a dummy
[ __ ] idiot mind control so if you had
a set of beliefs if they gave you enough
lsd and pumped all this propaganda in
you
yep he said it it was definitely
propaganda 100 percent
oh [ __ ] and by the way to answer your
small family farms we only sell the most
proper uganda
that's why we wake up at 4 00 a.m every
morning and pick the gander fresh for
you
uh hold on that's never frozen ganda
is because they thought your whole your
family recipe
[Laughter]
[Music]
russia and the nazis were doing it
already where they could use mind
control so if you had a set of beliefs
if they gave you enough lsd and
this propaganda in you that it would
make the lumineers tolerable
[Laughter]
all right i guess they're not that bad
they could clear whatever base you start
from and then insert their ideas
but really then and then they were also
working on by the way i like brian
kellett saying wow like his dad didn't
work for the cia
right i left brian's like wow for real
your dad was there bud
control because they thought the
russians figured out how to use mind
control and also they thought
they were curious if the mind could work
kind of how levin does yeah
if the mind could work kind of like no
see he's using stranger things as an
analogy
for mk ultra
you guys just not paying attention
it's ridiculous but what they found out
is they did also millie bobby brown is
18 so somebody let drake know that she's
done cooking
a lot of evil [ __ ] and what happened i
didn't forget drake
happens
she's done cooking drake [ __ ] go get her
they gave these people so much lsd it
really is wow
they're going the wrong way so if you
look at the people that went through
that mk ultra let me give you a few
whitey bulger do you know that i did not
whitey bulger from black
i did not know that whitey bulger was a
victim of mk ultra that's the first time
i'm hearing by the way you're right
though speaking look at his body
language too he crossed his arm he's in
a defensive posture already oh my god he
really is though that was just a joke
but you're right he isn't like he's like
my dad my daddy was nice shut up
my daddy was super cool bro
martel or uh
yes he only knew
about whitey bulger from the movie black
mass yeah he didn't know about whitey
bulger outside of that these people are
very stupid frozen i don't know if you
know this
manson was heavy in the empty true yeah
oh yeah this is also so this is ultra so
whitey bulger and whitey bulger charles
manson ready for this the una bomber ted
consists
he went oh he tried kaczynski so hard he
tried so hard not to [ __ ] that one up
let me give me it again i i don't need
oh you got it oh no i needed to i need
to mainline this hold on let me see
charles manson ready for this the una
bomber ted consent kazansi went through
ted kenzinski
ted kenneth ted kenneth zinsky
uh right into the femoral on that one
goddamn that's good
[ __ ] now it's a cut scene like from
equilibrium where my [ __ ] eyes open
up
when he takes the pills you know what i
mean
but the only thing about that's a little
dicey with ted dicey dicey
do we have a brendan bingo card we need
one right
when they were interviewed wrong yeah
and when he got caught you know they uh
someone brought up when he was at
harvard they ran all these mind control
[ __ ] on him the mk ultra [ __ ] and uh his
mom said to his brother because his
brother had a
a suspicion that maybe it was his
brother who's the unabomber you know
who's the biggest manhunt 50 million
dollars in taxpayers money ted kaczynski
was right i mean not with the mailing of
the bomb things but everything else
was he wrong did you read his manifesto
was he wrong
it's hard to fight it nope
mother read the notes called all of the
[ __ ] for example tesla's ted kaczynski
was right if we let technology get too
big you'll have shows like the fighter
and the kid and that'll be just horrible
for all of us
yeah dude
god that sounds a lot like my brother
damn so he went and asked his mom i was
like damn that's thoughtful when you're
introspection you say hello
because it's thoughtful damn damn man
damn bro bruh that's so wild bro bruh
bro [ __ ] stop
you're none of you were deep you none of
you were deep you're all bunch of [ __ ]
i'm an idiot i'll admit it but you guys
act like you're smarter than you are
you're all a bunch of dummies
there's no way
oh what's in the show links
which one
uh the the latest one from cali speed
there it is
no propaganda on features today
propaganda
i can't it's gonna be a thing now this
is gonna be a thing he's one of the he's
so
he's so stupid
you know
you believe that mom like there's no way
and he brought up those
uh i don't know maybe
uh if you have if you're going to use
the word proper oh yeah now i'm just
doing it
proparganda
no it's infected us it's a mind virus
it's propaganda from now
it's actually pronounced it's actually
pronounced john papa randa
um the mk ultra stuff when he was at
harvard and she goes it's not that she
was she was that that didn't help but
it's not that she's like your brother's
always had an issue
like he has a
sociopathic type of way your brother has
an issue because
you know you're his older brother so
and she goes i can tell you what
happened when he was a very young
he got some illness
but good thing his dad was a badass dime
piece with a computer salesman degree
because if you're not
yeah we don't be [ __ ] bro
bro
dicey dicey dog
and for whatever reason they put him in
this hospital he was young
proper ganja about that
[Laughter]
young like six months old eight months
old when enough where you can kind of
remember but you know you at six eight
months old you really need your mom your
parents but they put them in this
hospitals hospital for whatever reason
had this program where they kept the kid
for months
so what do they what they do on their
show is they just
they just
watch certificate about propaganda well
not even that they watch netflix
documentaries
right
and
then he describes them but poorly
it's like cte cliff note